MIHAI IONESCU: Hello everyone.
My name is Mihai Ionescu.
PENG YING: And I'm Peng Ying.
MIHAI IONESCU: And welcome to
another session of Google
Payments Live.
This is our first office hour
since Google I/O, and we had
some very exciting announcements
at Google I/O.
We'll do a recap of those, and
of course we'll go over
questions posted on our
moderator page.
So, Peng, what happened on
Google I/O, and what kind of
announcements do
you have there?
PENG YING: Cool.
We made some huge announcements
at I/O. A few
things that we announced were
the Save to Wallet API which
allows you to save offers
your Wallet.
And we announced a few
updates and new
features of In-App Payments.
So I'll cover a few during our
session today, and then Mihai
is going to cover
a few as well.
The new features and
functionality are, we launched
subscriptions.
In addition to that,
we announced
a new pricing structure.
So why don't you tell them what
the pricing structure is.
MIHAI IONESCU: Sure.
So we got a lot of feedback from
developers and merchants.
They were really happy with our
5% pricing structure, one
of the most aggressive
in the industry.
But we also heard that for
larger payments, they would
like to have a more flexible
structure that
reflects larger amounts.
So we're very happy to announce
that at Google I/O,
we introduced a pricing
structure based on a 1.9% rate
plus a fixed amount and
a 5% rate depending
on the payment amount.
So this will adjust
automatically to give
developers the most
favorable rate.
PENG YING: Yeah, it's great.
I mean it's great for a lot of
developers who are actually
choosing larger order values.
So something like, for example,
one of the partners
who was presenting with us,
Kabam, they had an average
order size of something
like $45.
And 5% isn't that great, but
1.9% and $0.30 is amazing.
So I think if you go out and
you talk to credit card
processors, I think the lowest
fee that they typically give
out is somewhere around
1.9% and $0.30.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, so you
can't get better than that.
And you'll notice that the
threshold where we switch from
5% to the 1.9% rate is around
$9 or so for US dollars.
It will be different in other
currencies, so check which one
is best for you.
PENG YING: Not to mention that
Google Wallet for digital
goods is a super easy
API to implement.
So if you're thinking about
monetizing a web app now or
sometime soon, be sure to take
a look at the documentation.
We're actually going to
go through some of the
subscriptions, changes,
and JSON Web Token
documentation today.
And the link for the
presentation that we gave at
I/O is bit.ly/gwdgslides.
That's Google Wallet for
digital goods slides.
And do you just want
to cover it now?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, sure.
Let's go look at the slides--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PENG YING: Let's take a look
at the slides, specifically
the slides about what changed
before, how to add
subscriptions to your
JSON Web Token.
MIHAI IONESCU: So let's
switch to the slides.
PENG YING: Cool.
What you see on the screen
right now is the JSON Web
Token that defines a
subscription item.
If you're not familiar with
JSON Web Tokens, it's
basically a method to encode
some JSON and append a
signature to it.
Because of the way the API
works, it's a JavaScript call
to initiate the purchase flow,
all of your information passes
through the client side.
And in order to secure this
information on the client
side, we pretty much append a
signature or use a JSON Web
Token for our standard to append
a signature to the data
to make sure that it hasn't
been altered.
What you're seeing here is the
item itself, an item that
defines a subscription item.
And the differences are
highlighted in yellow.
So here, the type is a
little bit different.
It's a Google Payments In-App
subscription, and it's v1.
And then, within the item
request itself, you're
defining the initial item,
like it could be initial
purchase, something like
prorated, or it could be a
free trial for a month,
or anything else.
And then you're defining
the recurrence.
Right now we only support
monthly frequency, but in the
future, we hope to support a few
more different time cycles
like biweekly, annually,
weekly, daily.
So we'll give a lot of different
options to the
developers.
Is there anything I'm
missing Mihai?
MIHAI IONESCU: I think
that covers it.
So, as you can see, it's
very easy to implement
subscription.
Once you've implemented the
single-item payment,
subscription is just a matter
of adding a few lines to the
JWT and processing some
extra callbacks.
Now why don't you talk a
little bit about the
difference in callbacks
for subscriptions.
PENG YING: Sure.
So there's one main difference
in the callback, and this
occurs when a subscription
is canceled.
So when a user decides to cancel
a subscription within
their buyer center, you'll get
a notification on your server
saying that we can no longer
process the subscription.
And your server should then end
their access to whatever
content that you were
providing them.
So all this documentation
can be found on
our Developer's Guide.
And the Developer's Guide can
be found at developers.googl
e.com/in-app-payments.
Plural.
So yeah, take a look at it.
It's there if you're
interested.
And it's really, really
easy to integrate.
I mean, we can go through the
slides and then speak a little
bit to the integration, but it's
basically define the JSON
Web Token, call our JavaScript
library, and that initiates a
purchase flow.
And there's some postback
handling, but that's really
easy as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great, so, to
recap what we did at I/O. A
new pricing structure based on
feedback from developer.
For larger transactions with
high order value, we now
charge 1.9% plus a fixed fee.
And for microtransactions, it's
still 5%, and you will
get the most favorable
rate automatically.
And of course, also based on
developer feedback and
requests, we added subscription
support, which
very simply and naturally can
be integrated with your
existing integration.
Great.
PENG YING: And there's more
coming, probably.
MIHAI IONESCU: And there is
more coming, stay tuned.
PENG YING: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
MIHAI IONESCU: So you can
start integrating
subscriptions right now.
They are available
in the Sandbox.
Very soon, we plan to release
them into production.
If you have any issues, we have
a group where you can ask
questions or at our next office
hours session, we can
go over any of those issues.
PENG YING: These are biweekly
by the way, so we'll be
covering any questions
that you have
about Google Payments.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great,
so let's move on and
look at some questions.
So questions that we got from
our moderator page.
PENG YING: We can also talk
about Google developer
accounts, the other thing we
released at Google I/O.
MIHAI IONESCU: So many new
things to talk about.
So let's look at one
more thing here.
So, also since I/O, we launched
a new site for
developers, which is called
Google Developer Academy.
So it's at
developers.google.com/academy.
And if you go there, you'll
find a lot tutorials and
courses covering all kinds
of Google APIs.
And in particular for Google
Wallet, we have a new course
called Google Wallet for digital
goods, which gives you
a step-by-step tutorial on how
to integrate the API with your
web application.
Very simple.
Go have a look just
for simple steps.
And of course, we have a sample
app that will guide you
through all these steps.
And in less than a day, you can
be set up and start making
some money.
So
developers.google.com/academy.
Right, so let's now take
some questions.
PENG YING: Yeah, we're taking
some questions from the--
what was it called again?
MIHAI IONESCU: On our moderator
page, and maybe you
have some others from
other sources.
So let's see.
Since we've been talking about
subscriptions, we have a
couple about subscriptions,
so let's address those.
So, for subscription,
is monthly the
only supported frequency?
PENG YING: Well, right
now, monthly is the
only supported frequency.
Like I said, we're looking
to support
additional ones in the future.
It's only in sandbox right now,
and I don't really know
the backend code that well, but
I imagine is like similar
to setting up a separate job
or some time schedule.
So it shouldn't be
too difficult.
I guess we're trying to just
get it out in the wild and
have developers start
using it.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'd also like to
hear some feedback on what
particular frequency would be
more useful for developers.
Is it bimonthly, you want
to charge weekly?
It would be great to know.
PENG YING: Yeah, and I think
we'll also do something like
we will enable developers to
have a separate API call to
initiate their recurrence
requests.
So you could say, oh I want to
make 12 recurrences, and then
you schedule it yourself.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
So also subscription related,
when are you launching the new
subscription API into
production?
When will that happen?
PENG YING: That's another
question, but because it's
Google, unfortunately we can't
share specific dates.
But we know that's
coming very soon.
I hope you all are
enjoying it.
I hope you all are playing
around with it in Sandbox.
And the API won't
change at all.
So, in order to change a
production when production is
ready, all you have to do is
change production config in
the loader, and you have to
switch out your Seller ID and
Seller Secret when you're
defining your JSON Web Tokens.
MIHAI IONESCU: So it may happen
sooner than you think.
If you plan to have
subscriptions get ready,
implementing the Sandbox, and
then it'll be just a matter of
flicking a switch to enable
it in production.
All right, so one more
question related to
subscription.
There's another one.
Is Google Pay subscriptions a
solution for software as a
service application
subscriptions?
Sure.
PENG YING: Yeah, sounds like
it should be fine.
MIHAI IONESCU: Sounds
like a great fit.
It depends, again, based on
the previous question, how
often do you want to charge
the customer?
But it sounds like an excellent
fit, and you can add
additional application and
additional subscriptions as
you see fit.
So go play with it, and let
us know how it works.
PENG YING: Yeah.
So Google Wallet for digital
goods had been optimized for
digital goods.
I mean, if you're selling
something like a service, you
can also use it.
It just depends on what
additional information you
need to provide within the
purchase experience that
sometimes Google Wallet
for digital goods
may or may not support.
But I think in this case, where
they're trying to sell
software as a service, that it
should be completely fine.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
OK, so we covered the
subscription questions.
Let's take one about
currencies.
So, one developer says his
merchant account is in euros,
but he would like to charge
users in a different currency,
probably in another European
country which does not use the
euro currency.
Is that possible?
So let's take an example.
Let's say you are in euros and
you want to charge in British
pounds, so from euro to GBP.
Yes, it is possible, and you
can find the available
currencies listed in
our documentation.
You would just need to specify
the new currency in the JWT
when you place the
payment request.
What will happen, the user
will be charged in that
particular currency, let's
say British pounds.
And on his credit card
statements, everything will be
in British pounds.
You, however, will receive the
payout in your local currency,
which in this case is euros,
and the transaction, the
exchange, will happen
automatically at the best rate
of the day.
So you don't have to worry
about any of those.
You just have to make sure you
charge the user in the amount
you want in his local currency,
and then you will
automatically get the funds in
the currency of your account.
Everything happening
transparently at the
best rate for you.
PENG YING: And we pull something
like every hour,
every two hours, against the
forex rate, so we typically
have pretty decent rates,
pretty accurate rates.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, let's
get another one.
We have a couple of questions
about adding other debit,
credit cards to the Google
Wallet account.
I'm not sure if this is related
to the Google Payments
API or just the in-store
Wallet account.
PENG YING: So I think that one
may be for adding additional
cards into the offline wallet,
into NFC wallet.
That's what it sounds like.
That is another good question.
I mean, we're always trying to
expand the availability and
usability of Wallet.
Right now, it's Citi
MasterCards, but we are
looking to expand.
I would say to stay tuned for
announcements in the future.
I mean, this is Google, we can't
pre-announce anything.
I'd love to be like, yes.
But we'll see what comes
down the road.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
And with Payments right now,
users can use their credit
card or debit card for
the online API.
PENG YING: Online Payments
supports all credit cards, all
major networks.
It's just the offline NFC
portion that is limited to
Citi Mastercards right now.
MIHAI IONESCU: And of course,
we're looking to add new forms
of payment to both, including
local forms of payment.
Good, so we covered that.
Let's see.
There's a question about
using Google
Wallet on a rooted phone.
So I think that one has been
also answered in the past.
We strongly recommend not to
install or use Google Wallet
on a rooted phone.
The reason is, when you root the
phone, you remove an extra
layer of security.
So of course, you can use it,
but then you have to know
what's happening on your
phone, and you'll be
responsible for any applications
trying to steal
your PIN or do stuff
like that.
So the short answer
is, don't do it.
Use Google Wallet on
a non-rooted phone
for your own security.
OK, we have anything else?
PENG YING: I don't know.
Are there any more questions?
MIHAI IONESCU: They're along the
same lines about loyalty
cards to Google Wallet.
So as we said, we are
looking into that
and plan to add those.
PENG YING: So right now, the
loyalty card world is kind of
interesting.
There's a lot of different
providers, a lot of different
proprietary systems.
So we're still investigating
different possibilities of
loyalty cards for
offline Wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
I think this is it for this
week, and we'll see you back
again in two weeks.
PENG YING: Yeah, so just a note,
we'll be doing a couple
different formats.
And sometimes we'll invite some
people from the risk team
here so they can answer
questions about, what are
risky transactions, how
do I minimize my risky
transactions?
Why are some of my orders
canceled, and
so on and so forth.
In addition to that, we'll
probably review some of the
applications that we find
really good or that are
monetizing very well, and then
invite them in to speak with
them about their experiences.
So, stay tuned.
We'll be on every two weeks,
every other week.
Post any questions
that you have.
Tell us what you want, and we
will try to fill your needs.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Bye.
PENG YING: Cool, see you.